if you thought facebook and apple were
already going through a
war on privacy you haven't seen anything
yet
because both facebook and apple are
betting on a future
where virtual reality headsets and
augmented reality smart glasses
will go mainstream in fact facebook
reported their earnings a couple of days
ago
and in their earnings call mark
zuckerberg mentioned that facebook
would transition from being a social
media company to a
metaverse company he even mentioned the
word metaverse
20 times which he defines as a virtual
environment
where you can be present with people in
digital spaces
or even further an embodied internet
that you're inside of
rather than just looking at remember the
movie ready player one where everyone
puts on a vr headset and socializes
within
the oasis yep basically something like
that
especially since facebook has already
announced horizon
a massive multiplayer world that is
meant to be
just like the oasis so facebook's
metaverse goal is based on two different
things
virtual reality headsets like facebook's
wildly successful oculus quest 2
and of course facebook's future
augmented reality smart glasses
and considering the fact that almost a
fifth of facebook's employees
are now working on these vr and ar
headsets
facebook is pretty serious about this
being the future
meanwhile apple is also rumored to be
working on their own
high-end virtual reality headset and
their own
augmented reality smart glasses so
they'll be directly competing with
facebook but with a far greater focus on
privacy
and protecting user data but before i
get into apple's part of the vr headset
story
i want to get into the history of
facebook's efforts in
the metaverse space in 2014 facebook
bought out the vr headset company oculus
after the success of their oculus rift
headset
with mark zuckerberg claiming that
oculus has the chance to change the way
we work
play and communicate at the time mark
even mentioned his vision
of people putting on an oculus vr
headset and doing things like studying
in a classroom of students and teachers
all over the world
or consulting a doctor face to face
just by putting on goggles in your own
home but during the phase of the
acquisition
oculus fans and supporters were
extremely upset
about facebook buying them out even
saying that they're done with oculus
because of the deal so the founder of
oculus headed to reddit
and personally guaranteed that users
would not need to log into their
facebook account
every time they want to use their oculus
rift well
unfortunately in 2018 facebook required
users to link
their facebook and oculus accounts
together in order to access oculus
venues and then just last year facebook
began
forcing oculus owners to log into their
facebook account
basically breaking the initial promise
that the founder of oculus made and
going even deeper
back in 2014 he promised that they
wouldn't track users
flash ads at them or do anything
invasive
well in 2019 facebook announced that
they will now
track your vr data to make ads more
relevant
if you're logged into facebook which
they now obviously require
and just to give you an idea of what
they're tracking here's all of the data
that facebook would capture
about your vr use also including your
voice activities
moving on in june of this year oculus
announced that they began to test
in headset vr advertisements something
that they promised
they would not do and if you're
wondering why facebook would do this
well it turns out that according to
steam's hardware survey
oculus vr headsets now make up over
60 percent of the total vr headset usage
on steam
with the most recent oculus quest 2
headset taking up
a massive 31 alone
with by far the fastest growth of almost
1
over the past month in fact facebook
says that the quest 2
has already outsold every previous
oculus headset combined
and it did it in its first six months of
being on the market
and just by looking at this chart of top
vr headset brand market share
it's pretty clear that oculus has
basically taken over the entire market
since the launch of the quest 2 in the
fourth quarter of
2020 and this is what the market share
looks like for the quest 2
compared to the top competitors in the
first quarter of 2021
with oculus now selling a total of 4.6
million
quest 2 headsets as of july 14th
just 9 months after its launch now
you're probably wondering
why is this new headset so popular well
the quest 2 is a fully standalone
headset
that doesn't require a connected console
or pc
and it also packs very impressive specs
at the same time
and all of this comes at a mind
blowingly low price of only 299 dollars
which is so cheap that it doesn't make
any sense at all
well maybe it does because an analyst
named leo jebby
claims that the 299 dollar price means
that it's being sold at
incredibly low or even lost leading
margins
which means that facebook is likely
selling it at a loss
similar to what sony has done in the
past with some of their playstation
consoles
instead relying on game sales to make
profits
so the million dollar question is why
would facebook
sell the oculus quest 2 at a loss
well here's an explanation from mark
zuckerberg himself
facebook wants to offer these products
at as low of a cost as possible
in order to be able to get them out to
everyone
which is basically what has already
happened according to the steam hardware
survey results
and the sales numbers and the analyst
leo jabi
believes that with this strategy
facebook has basically priced
all of their competitors out of the
market basically creating a monopoly in
the vr headset space
and if we really dig deep the real
reason why facebook was able to get the
price down so low
is because from the very beginning they
knew they were planning on serving ads
to vr headset wearers which is
incredibly shady
because facebook waited until they sold
millions of quest to headsets
and essentially became a vr monopoly
before finally admitting that they're
gonna enable ads
and in facebook's earnings call just a
couple of days ago
the word advertising was mentioned 28
times
with mark zuckerberg claiming that
advertising will be
an important part of facebook strategy
to profit off of the
metaverse and on top of all of that they
just announced that they're doubling the
storage of the quest
2 while keeping the same exact 299
price tag basically making it impossible
for any of their competitors to compete
and this is where we get into apple's
part of the story
a future competitor that will go a
completely different route
with their vr headset as all of us know
at this point
apple has recently been battling
facebook on the issue of
privacy with the goal of keeping their
customers data
as safe as possible even allowing iphone
users
to easily stop apps like facebook from
tracking their online activity
so if and when apple releases a vr
headset
we already know that it's going to be
much more expensive
because apple won't be serving ads to
their customers and apple won't be
collecting user data
against their own will which is
definitely going to attract
a lot of customers who care about
privacy and luckily for apple
the oculus quest 2 was just recalled
due to facial interface issues that can
apparently cause rashes
like you see in this photo so with that
let's now dig into a bunch of leaks to
see
what we should expect from apple in
terms of a future vr headset
apple has been working on a vr headset
ever since they started publishing
patents
for video goggles all the way back in
2013
and three years later they hired a
leading virtual reality researcher
and dedicated hundreds of employees to a
secret research unit
for ar and vr headsets and earlier this
year
mark german from bloomberg who is the
most reliable apple leaker
claimed that apple's first vr headset
would be a pricey
niche precursor to apple's more
ambitious ar
glasses and he even mentioned that they
would be launching in 2022
to compete with facebook's oculus
headset among
other rivals the information then came
out with the leak
claiming that the vr headset would
feature dual 8k displays
with eye tracking which is much better
spec than facebook's quest
2 that uses dual 2k displays and
apparently apple's vr headset will come
packed with over a
dozen cameras to track both hand and eye
movements
and going even further the information
claims that they actually viewed a late
stage prototype
that should look something like this and
apparently
they think it could cost as much as 3
000
which is absolutely insane but luckily
ming shaquille came out a couple of
months ago
and claimed that the vr headset would
cost around a thousand dollars
which is a much more believable price in
a couple of weeks ago
a twitter user named scoble claimed that
apple's vr headset would launch at next
year's wwdc event
alongside a new ipod which would
actually be
the perfect apple event to release this
headset in my opinion so with all that
said
if apple's vera headset does release
next year
it for sure will outperform and outspect
the oculus quest 2 while at the same
time
providing greater security and privacy
protection
but for a much higher a thousand dollar
or so
price tag but in my opinion facebook is
still going to dominate the vr headset
market
with their much cheaper 300 quest 2
since they've been working on the
platform and game library for a long
time
while on the other hand a much smaller
amount of people who really care about
privacy and
quality will go for apple's headset if
they're willing to deck out
the high amount of cash but the story
doesn't end there
because the main part of the metaverse
actually has to do with facebook's and
apple's
future augmented reality smart glasses
which could potentially go as
viral as the modern smartphone and if
you're interested in what apple and
facebook could be doing
with their smart glasses go ahead and
click the circle above to subscribe for
more videos like this one
definitely check out one of those two
right there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in
the next video